Companies across the world talk about employee relations,...
...and they talk about employees are their most important product.
Most of it is hogwash.
But most of them don't really believe in training, in building teams and investing in people.
Investing in people is the whole ball game.
When you invest in people and when you give them your trust,...
...and they give you their trust, and you both drive towards a common vision...,
...and you explain to them what's in it for them,...
...not just where you're going, where you're going, yes,...
...but what's in it for them to go there.
You build great teams with great results.
And that's what this is all about.
And people don't get that.
People don't understand that you've got to invest in training.
You've got to invest, you've got to get the culture that's common,...
...the values that are common,...
...so that people know where they're going and why they're going there.